so David you do admit that UFOs exist
well what does UFO mean it means
unidentified flying object it's
different than intelligent alien species
from another country and yet another one
of these UFOs has been shot down by the
United States increasingly the question
is what exactly are these the latest
claim is they are in the balloon
category generally similar to that first
surveillance balloon believed to be from
China that was shot down off the coast
of South Carolina but not exactly the
same and it is still early days and we
are trying to gather information so
let's go to what we know and what took
place CNN reporting on Saturday U.S jet
shoots down unidentified object over
Northern Canada
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
said Saturday an unidentified object had
been shot down by a U.S fighter jet over
Canadian airspace on his orders I
ordered the takedown of an unidentified
object that violated Canadian airspace
NORAD command shot down the object over
the Yukon Canadian and U.S aircraft were
scrambled and a usf-22 successfully
fired at the object the object is being
described as cylindrical and smaller
than the suspected Chinese balloon shot
down last weekend according to Canadian
defense minister anina Anand
later Saturday the White House confirmed
Trudeau and Joe Biden authorized the
shoot down and the Pentagon said the
object was first spotted over Alaska on
Friday evening immediately questions
about was this the same thing or not was
it in the category is ballooned the
right word here is what Senator Chuck
Schumer said after being briefed by
National Security adviser Jake Sullivan
until they get that comprehensive
analysis however we have to look at each
balloon individually
they believe they were yes but much
smaller than the uh than the one the
first one both of those one over Canada
one over Alaska were 40 000 feet
immediately it was determined that
that's a danger to commercial aircraft
yeah so um there are sort of conspiracy
types who are saying wait a second
cylindrical object is very different
than balloon soon everybody is lying to
us right now I have no reason in
particular to think anybody is lying to
us but we do need more information of
course we also have now been presented
with the claim from China that the
United States has done the exact same
thing 10 times there is a CNN article
from this morning China accuses U.S of
illegally flying balloons across its
airspace China has accused the U.S of
illegally flying a high altitude
balloons into its airspace more than 10
times since January 2022 claims that
Drew an immediate rebuttal from the
White House will hear that rebuttal in a
moment
as bilateral tensions flare in the
Fallout from the Chinese balloon that
was shot down by American fighter jets
after traveling across the continental
U.S let's look at a clip here of the
National Security council's John Kirby
very clearly just denying that the U.S
does the same thing take a listen
and I believe we have the clip here
do we have the clip let's see
I love having Clips Jing just in the
last hour or two the four Ministry there
has accused the United States since the
start of 2022 of flying balloons 10
different times over Chinese airspace
can you respond to that accusation not
true not doing it just absolutely not
true so the U.S let me just push you a
little further that so the U.S is not
using these balloons Technologies at all
over China
that is right we are not flying balloons
uh over China that is absolutely true
Now understand
whenever such a statement is made
in colloquial language we would say this
is a complete denial
if you want to play these cynical games
which are very often accurate right I
mean we we call them games but there's a
reason we play them
when he's there's a couple critical
words there balloons and over China his
statement and I hate that this is the
way stuff is communicated these days I
am not arguing that such a thing is or
isn't taking place his statement is
balloons aren't being flown over China
could balloons be flown off the coast of
China and he wouldn't be lying yeah
could there be something other than a
balloon flown over China and he wouldn't
be lying yeah so again you always want
to pay really close attention to the
language that's being used I'm not
suggesting one thing or the other we're
just kind of parsing through it okay and
then lastly then just as will there be
this will that Viewpoint be expressed
directly to Beijing Beyond here on the
friendly confines of Morning Joe uh when
when do the next conversation start
between Washington and Beijing over a
matter that's clearly inflaming tensions
between the two countries well two
points there Jonathan first of all we
still have diplomatic relations with
China we still have an embassy there
it's not like all Communications between
us and the PRC have shut down obviously
there are certain Vehicles like military
to military vehicles which are not open
to us right now and that's unfortunate
but we do have the ability to
communicate directly with the Chinese
leaders and we have okay so relations
are still ongoing although Kirby says we
are absolutely not doing the same thing
so a couple different things going on
here number one uh do we do we want to
and should we figure out what exactly
these um uh unidentified flying objects
are of course we should is it likely
that at this point official sources know
more than they are saying publicly
absolutely is it likely that the U.S is
doing equivalent surveillance in China
to what China is doing in the U.S of
course it might just take different
forms this is what countries do it
applies to Russia it applies to many
different countries and lastly at this
time do you have any reason to believe
that these are intelligent aliens we do
not and of course I am mathematically
and statistically open to the
possibility of intelligent life out
there in the universe do I believe it is
this these these objects that represent
that I have no reason whatsoever to
believe that that's the case are you
tired of the same old off-the-shelf
grocery store honey look no further than
manukura our sponsor the honey is made
by bees that pollinate the native Manuka
trees in the remote forests of New
Zealand it gives it a unique dark Rich
delicious flavor that you won't find in
any other honey it is 100 raw if you
look at it side by side with regular
boring honey you can see the difference
I've got my Honeys next to each other on
the counter and it looks very different
manukura is also responsible and
sustainable all manukura honey is
harvested using traditional methods so
you can enjoy your creamy caramel honey
knowing that the production was easy on
the bees and on the planet it's a
perfect natural sweetener I've been
adding it to my tea and my toast but
because of the amazing complex flavor I
find myself using it in things I didn't
even put honey in before like oatmeal
and yogurt and smoothies I have to admit
my girlfriend once caught me tasting
Manuka Honey right off the spoon because
it's that good it really stands out from
everyday honey so don't settle for the
ordinary honey when you can enjoy the
unique delicious flavor of manukora go
to manukora.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for a free pack of honey sticks
very nostalgic to when I was a kid with
your order a 15 value tastes the
difference for yourself the link is down
below